en el último vídeo lo que hicimos para
encontrar las fórmulas para la
frecuencia observada y el período
observado desde el punto de vista de un
observador que se encontraba en este
punto era un observador que se
encontraba en la trayectoria de la
fuente el puntito este que está
emitiendo la onda se está moviendo justo
hacia el observador es el caso en el que
uno está parado muy cerca de las vías
del tren de hecho debería estar parado
en medio de las vías del tren y lo que
observamos es que el sonido del tren es
mucho más agudo desde el punto de vista
de ese observador
esta es la frecuencia que él observa y
este es el periodo que este observador
observado y como le hacíamos para
obtener todas estas fórmulas pues lo que
hacíamos era pensar en cómo sucedían las
cosas el emisor de la onda o sea este
puntito la fuente emitía una onda y
pensábamos en donde se encontraba la
cresta de esa onda después de ts
segundos recordemos que t s
es el periodo de la onda desde la fuente
o sea cuánto tiempo tarda la fuente en
repetir toda la secuencia de la onda
entonces desde cierta cantidad de tiempo
y decíamos que la cresta de la onda se
encontraba en este punto esta
circunferencia después de ts segundos
después de un periodo y después de un
periodo justo la onda se vuelve a
repetir o sea justo en este segundo la
fuente va a emitir la siguiente cresta
pero la fuente el puntito que emite las
ondas ya se transladó porque se está
moviendo a una velocidad de ese hacia la
derecha que es justo hacia donde se
encuentra nuestro observador y lo que
hacíamos entonces es medir este
observador cuánto tiempo se va a tardar
en escuchar a la segunda que está la que
se está emitiendo en este momento que
como la fuente ya se trasladó hasta acá
la onda se empieza a emitir desde este
punto aquí este circulito verde
esta es la siguiente cresta y para medir
cuánto tiempo se va a tardar en escuchar
la siguiente cresta dado que está
escuchando la 1a
lo que tenemos que hacer es calcular
esta distancia y dividirla entre la
velocidad con la que la onda se propaga
en este medio porque si esta cresta
tiene que recorrer cierta distancia para
que este observador le escuche y
dividimos entre la velocidad con la que
la onda se mueve entonces lo que vamos a
obtener es cuánto tiempo se va a tardar
esta cresta en llegar hasta este punto y
bueno esta distancia la calculamos y
pues es esta distancia
- esta distancia esta distancia la
calculamos multiplicando el periodo o
sea la cantidad de tiempo que le dimos a
esta primera onda para propagarse por la
velocidad con la que se propaga la onda
entonces esta distancia es wv por ts y
esta distancia es cuánto tiempo le dimos
a la fuente para moverse desde este
punto hacia la derecha por la velocidad
con la que este punto el punto la fuente
de la onda se mueve hacia la derecha y
entonces esta distancia es bs por t s
por lo tanto esta distancia tiene que
ser esta cosa de acá que es lo mismo que
esto y si lo dividimos entre la
velocidad con la que la onda se propaga
lo que nos da es cuánto tiempo se va a
tardar esta segunda cresta en llegar al
observador si el observador está ahorita
escuchando la primera cresta y a eso es
a lo que nosotros le llamamos el periodo
observado por este observador y la
frecuencia observada es simplemente uno
entre el periodo observado y ahora
queremos hacer exactamente lo mismo pero
desde este observador ok vamos a
calcular el periodo observado y la
frecuencia observada desde este punto ya
no cuando la persona se encuentra justo
en medio de las vías del tren y el tren
va corriendo hacia esa persona sino
cuando la persona se encuentra en las
vías del tren pero el tren se está
alejando de la persona o sea el tren ya
no va a matar a nuestro observador ya
nada más está alejando de él
entonces para calcular la frecuencia y
el periodo desde este observador lo
primero que tenemos que hacer es
calcular esta distancia
qué bueno en realidad debería de medirse
desde aquí pero la nariz de este
observador tendría que estar por acá y
para calcular esta distancia ya tenemos
todos los elementos ya tenemos esta
distancia que es exactamente igual a
esta distancia o sea ya tenemos wv por
de s
a esta distancia le tenemos que sumar
esta distancia o sea le tenemos que
sumar bs por t s
y obviamente dividirlo entre la
velocidad con la que se propaga la onda
y a esa velocidad la denotamos por w
que ese es el período observado desde
este observador
y factor izando al igual que con esta
fórmula eso lo que nos queda es que el
período observado es igual a el periodo
que tiene la fuente por aquí lo que
hicimos fue factorizar ts o sea que nos
queda
wv más de ese entre wv
y entonces la frecuencia observada
es igual a 1 / ts y eso lo que es es
simplemente la frecuencia de la fuente
por 1 entre este paréntesis que es wv o
sea la velocidad de la onda entre wv más
de s
y listo estas son las fórmulas para la
frecuencia observada desde el punto de
vista de un observador que se encuentra
sobre las guías del tren pero donde el
tren se está alejando del observador
también se pueden calcular estas
cantidades el período observado y la
frecuencia observada para observadores
que no se encuentren sobre la
trayectoria del objeto que se mueve del
objeto que emite la onda por ejemplo
nuestro observador podría estar por acá
o en cualquier lugar pero estas fórmulas
se vuelven más complicadas y si tenemos
que saber exactamente en dónde se
encuentra nuestro observador lo que
vamos a hacer ahora es ver un ejemplo
concreto el mismo ejemplo que vimos hace
algunos vídeos cuando estábamos
introduciendo el efecto doble para que
todo quede más asentado y concreto en el
ejemplo teníamos una velocidad de la
fuente o sea el puntito se movía a 5
metros sobre segundos hacia la derecha y
la onda se propagaba con una velocidad
de 10 metros sobre segundo radialmente
hacia afuera entonces la velocidad de la
onda
10 metros sobre segundo radialmente
hacia afuera
el periodo desde la fuente no el
observador era de un segundo por ciclo o
sea cada segundo emitía otra cresta o
cada segundo completaba toda la
secuencia de la onda y por lo tanto la
frecuencia desde la fuente no la
frecuencia observada que es uno entre el
periodo es igual a 1 hertz
entonces veamos cuál es la frecuencia
observada desde el punto de vista de
este observador y la fórmula para este
observador es justo esta frecuencia lo
único que tenemos que hacer es sustituir
esta información en esta fórmula
entonces la frecuencia desde la fuente
es un hertz
un ciclo por segundo
la velocidad de la onda son 10 metros
sobre segundo
aquí también tenemos que poner 10 metros
sobre segundo y aquí se está restando
con la velocidad desde la fuente o sea 5
metros sobre segundo 5 metros sobre el
segundo
entonces reescribiendo todo esto porque
aquí no se entiende la frecuencia
observada desde ese observador que
estaba a la derecha en medio de las vías
del tren con el tren corriendo hacia él
ciclo por segundo
por 10 metros sobre segundo entre 10
metros sobre segundo menos 5 metros
sobre segundo
entonces hay metros sobre segundo arriba
y en cada uno de los factores de abajo
de esta fracción entonces estos metros
sobre segundos se van a cancelar y lo
que nos queda son 10 entre 10 menos 5 o
sea 10 entre 5 y eso es 2 y aquí tenemos
un 1 entonces lo que nos queda son 2
ciclos por segundo
entonces con esta información este
observador observo una frecuencia de dos
ciclos por segundo y ahora queremos
calcular cuál fue la frecuencia
observada desde este observador ok la
frecuencia desde la fuente sigue siendo
la misma un ciclo por segundo
la velocidad de la onda también es la
misma 10 metros sobre segundo
y lo que cambia aquí es que estos dos
valores en lugar de restar se van a
sumar pero la velocidad de la onda son
10 metros sobre segundo la velocidad de
la fuente son 5 metros sobre segundo
y entonces esta frecuencia observada son
un ciclo sobre segundo por
10 metros sobre segundo entre 10 metros
sobre segundo más 5 metros sobre segundo
los metros entre segundos se cancelan y
lo que nos queda son 10 entre 15 y eso
es igual a dos tercios entonces lo que
nos queda es que la frecuencia observada
son dos tercios
ciclo sobre segundo
entonces la frecuencia observada desde
este observador este
dos tercios de ciclos por segundo
y eso sí concuerda con lo que esperamos
este sí resultó ser más grande que éste
lo cual como son frecuencias significa
que esta persona va a escuchar un sonido
mucho más agudo y este observador está
otra persona lo que va a escuchar es un
sonido mucho más grave qué es lo que
pasa con las ambulancias y los trenes